hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to portal 2 with Schad
leech also known as Patrick say hi hello
okay so we were overthinking this
or I specifically was overthinking this
unleash the beast
ow why what did you even do I'm gonna do
anything even move
something happened okay unleash the
beast any day now he's unleashed no
again again you're doing it on purpose
I know for a fact you're doing it on
purpose and it's not good evening that
wasn't now I am okay unleash the beast
hah okay so the overthinking was we both
didn't need to be up here right away
because there's a portable wall right
there come on up link yeah that's why I
asked earlier
no no no no that I was I was using my
genius brain my genius brain was too
strong gosh 10 minutes oh hush your face
10 minutes isn't that valuable you you
want to know how much time I've wasted
on playing video games it's a lot like
all the miles yeah so anyway so we're
back and again whoa that looks weird
what the hell so are you gonna be on the
top and I'm gonna be on the bottom whoa
boy what is going on here I don't think
I want to know Wow oh no I'm gonna press
a button oh oh it's oh oh that's cool
the entire thing on here what does that
mean I have to run to every single
button before the ball gets to there I
don't know maybe or no no is there even
a ball is it just us trying to make you
go through um I'm not gonna make any
assumptions about what it may or may not
be until I have a better idea of what
I'm doing which apparently is nothing
well the person is a call button there
is not one of these might be a ball
button but the more important thing is
we need to coordinate because you
control some of these and then I control
some of these so I'm assuming I'm
assuming that the end and start paths
are here inside button okay okay okay so
that didn't work obviously but okay so
this is the in portal and this is the
out one so we need to get this to go to
VAX
so there is a ball I saw a ball yes
there's a ball it comes out of this one
so you need to push the button below
this one that button you need to push
that I need to push this one and then we
line this up so just follow this track
and eventually we'll get to where we
need to go so now this one needs this
one needs to be pushed
okay following this way doink doink
doink is connecting connecting
connecting connecting connecting
connecting connecting connecting okay
that connects push the ball button see
if that button will ball go see work
okay fire firing oh okay it's rolling
it's rolling it's going yes connecting
good velocity stable pressure is high
and running swimming good my butt is
tingling and caboose key where did it go
whoo hang on I just saw it it appeared
over here well hot diggity we did it
that was easy first fry other than when
it first puts the button yeah not bad
okay cowboy
did an excellent Hey placing the artless
safety cube in the receptacle okay to
celebrate I have a surprise for you cool
juggling test in three cake just let the
cake meme die you don't need to do
anything with cake I come back down here
seriously
that joke is literally older than I am
you'll get nothing but hate on the
internet if you mentioned cake and
nobody in the comments mentioned cake
observe the juggling balls of glory nice
very nice and then come this way you're
doing great you doing good so far oh
look we're done we did it tah-dah
not bad we finished one of the community
levels so hopefully we're gonna get
another one after this and then
everything is y'all so much pain okay
all right boink ow my grundle okay so
what do we got oh well I don't look good
okay you first
all right I'll go first cuz I'm the
brave one this goes here this goes here
walk through the portal oh wait all
right huh huh see joke's on you you
thought you're gonna die but the answer
was we were not well that doesn't look
good
ow ow well that's a lot of danger well
what are you talking about you died -
you're not on a better off I said I'm
gonna die and I'll died okay well
honesty is the best policy
okay so somehow huh we have to literally
time our portals very got here with you
well what we need to do is we need to
get through there alive what we need to
do is not get her [ __ ] blown to pieces
that's usually a good policy but not one
that I'm gonna take at this moment cuz I
have a strategy and it involves speeding
quickly through here so we don't get
shot to pieces okay okay ah no no no
okay it's not gonna work
that is the wrong strategy but the right
strategy is um as follows
no no I got it okay I got it I got a
hush hush your beautiful face BAM see we
need to go down here first before we can
do any groin you down there or do I have
to stay up here um let me see what the
sitch is first okay so you can come down
here I think okay so it looks like Jim
Ida why did you miss a really easy
question to ask aren't you miss okay I
just miss okay so that doesn't help
anybody
let's see but fat
does that help anybody that does not
that helps nobody do knowing here's that
one white wall up there still wears one
doing point to it where do you see it oh
I see something trying to not letting me
I know what goodbye I must go to my
people
ash [ __ ] I know I know what are your pee
I know what okay I'm going to goodbye a
goodbye cruel world goodbye goodbye I
know what to do I know I know what to do
I got it brain waves here out the wazoo
you're gonna see you're gonna be so
proud of me you're ready to be proud yes
ready to be PR OD proud okay
bang and AH Gottwald that you were just
that was the one I was talking about Shh
it's okay I know my genius is
intimidating okay so we gotta find a way
to go through there up there do you see
where I put it
do you see that I see yeah do you see
the power of my genius hope okay miss
that okay this is gonna kill me I'm
going to die I'm going to die okay
goodbye I died alright but that we got
put my fertile back
that's a good question why don't you
figure it out for yourself instead of
letting me do everything here oh one
portal there alright you do do it
there's no way to like fall
okay so I got it further in but the
robots are still a problem yeah they are
I mean I've done that before but I
haven't been
anywhere so yeah I linked it to continue
closer to them but still not gonna avoid
them uh-huh all right so we got to do
something I don't know what we're
missing something
oh wait never mind I'm right here ah
look at that I found a laser okay cool
look do you see do you see the laser you
see right there okay so yeah that is
gonna be useful somehow so we just got
to figure out a way to make that useful
so figure it out make it useful maybe oh
maybe oh hang on maybe that laser yea
jumped through the blue thing jump onto
the blue thing maybe the laser is gonna
protect you somehow you fool you daft
fool jump over the railing there yeah
okay I will keep you safe no promises
though I might not actually keep you
safe in fact I'm 100% sure that I won't
yeah yeah that didn't work why exactly
the laser supposed to kill why is the
laser there how do we get the laser Oh
unless we need oh I see it right here I
see it right here it's a reflector it's
a reflector box we need to get that
reflector box which means we need some
way to get momentum to be able to go
through that platform where my blue is
which I can do if I do this if I jump up
here I can do this okay so so if I go
over here and then I jump into my blue
which I can do that by doing there see
your blue huh oh fudge I missed okay so
everyone ignore that yeah that didn't
happen shhh I don't need your sass sass
is not required for this oh no you're
talking about okay but I got it you know
all about your sass okay guys I do my
friend I love you
all right here we go is it boink yes and
I overshot it yeah haha okay well listen
L III but that's the right track that's
on the right path so that is AG I am
still live somewhere what the hell I'm
still I have I have broken the matrix I
have entered a realm that I was not
supposed to go and I did not know uh
well you died but I'm still alive down
here so I've got a whole nest of other
problems because there's no portable
surfaces here and I don't know how to
Reese how do i oh man how do I blow
myself up how do I blow myself is there
a way to restart I'm gonna restart this
we're restarting cuz I I things went bad
there the reflector cube is an item that
allows you to bend or uh like turn light
a laser basically exactly the way you
needed to go so to do that I told the
cube but when the laser hits it wherever
you're a yes exactly exactly yes okay so
I just need to do this but I need to
adjust my momentum mid trajectory so
that I'm not terrible and die and don't
get stuck again I will not get stuck
again wow that's no problem
I might exactly get stuck again Robert
Lee here we go ah
no go I hit something in the midair
didn't mean to do that
whoopsies well at least I blew up that
time oh uh Thank You Russ but just bear
with me because I'm on the right
strategy here I know which way I do I
know how to do and I'm gonna do it
better at least this time okay here we
go I think I just need to jump from a
slightly not as high height which means
not from the railing but beggars can't
be choosers
okay you're wrong no it'll be fine I
miss it again ah oh yeah no no it's fine
it's on the right track it's on the
right path just let me be me no more
getting stuck I'm not gonna get stuck
Shh it's okay Shh it's okay
Oh duh oh of course
oh there's there's obviously I know how
to do this okay I know I know how to do
this okay so watch this if you if I Moo
oh [ __ ] where do I go what the what that
I don't know what just happened what did
I do
what happened that that was so weird
that was physically that physically
shouldn't have happened but I'll take it
and I love it okay get over here to
where I am cuz I need you to be on to
the portal that did yeah was it just
pops yeah just don't jump through it
just go through it oh [ __ ] no hang on
wait okay
no this is fine actually so you are oh
do I go in yeah go through there cuz you
need to activate the laser so let me
know when you're at the laser button
wait where's the laser jump through it
just jump okay drink it there ok now go
to the button alright so I'm gonna go on
the blue now if you want to be proactive
you can put the knot and we'll do that
later
okay I'm going to jump through okay
three two one laser now burn baby burn
burn burn burn I got him
I did it yeah okay now put your portal
down here and then send me on the other
side
okay so jump down there and place them
yeah I'm gonna keep this cube just in
case we need it thank you
see I knew you'd see it my way haha okay
come on through we got okay hey hi
ever testing again are you here yet
where are you
yo no no no hurry we don't have much
time actually while you're doing this
I'm gonna stay here and then embrace you
in a nice hug so that's all the time we
got for this episode thank you everybody
so much for watching we're gonna do one
more upset as we finish up this level
hug Oh are we hug I don't think we can
hug here anyway so thanks again and if
you want to check out Patrick's channel
it's shot leach there's a link in the
description below sorry I am suppressing
a hiccup right now
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video necessary to the
world like I cannot live in a world
where this game does not exist slot get
it up there I'm so sorry you're not